Donald Trump's Supreme Court
nominee Neil Gorsuch--
or as I'm referring to him,
Blanderson Cooper--
faced his second
confirmation hearing today,
and it's a very good thing
this is Comedy Central,
because he came ready to bring
with the laughs, people.
Take a look.
She can teach a monkey
how to read.
-I think she did.
-(chuckles)
I wrote this 800-page book on.
Makes a great doorstop,
gift for Christmas.
I cut a really bad deal
on royalties.
The robe
does mean something to me,
and not just that I can hide
the coffee stains on my shirt.
All right.
He's already disobeying
the Constitution,
because these jokes are cruel
and unusual punishment.
Comedians, he's clearly aiming
for a career as a stand-up,
so as a comedy club emcee,
I would like you to introduce
Neil Gorsuch.
-(bell dings)
-Emily.
Give it up
for your bar and waitstaff.
They all just lost
their health insurance.
-(laughter)
-Points.